did you know that the Lord has allowed
Satan free rein with the use of
spiritualism anything he can do under
the cloak of that banner that power he
can do God said go ahead do whatever you
want I often thought about that why why
would the Lord give him free ring and
then as I studied the spirit of prophecy
the Bible became pretty evident the
warnings are all over not to fool around
with that subject and he has given us so
much information so much light that says
don't mess around with the supernatural
that he has given Satan free reign to
use it in any way that he wants any way
that he wants now as Bauer has have a
quick little short prayer Lord be with
us this morning help us to have the love
in our hearts that you have for us that
selfless love that didn't even want life
without us it's hard to imagine Lord
that you are the creator of the universe
and you chose not to exist if we
couldn't be there with you incredible
Lord we want that love in our hearts
it's given to us as a gift from you so
thank you in Jesus name Amen
I'll say that again because it's just so
important to understand that when Jesus
had no hope on the cross not one ray of
hope could not see through the portals
of the tomb which of course that's the
second death that he had to die for us
the no hope thing but even though he had
no hope he could have stopped it and
saved himself but he didn't and I can't
help asking why wouldn't he do that why
wouldn't he save himself because he knew
that we wouldn't be there if he did and
his love for us is greater than a love
for himself that's what Heaven's all
about folks and we don't have that love
naturally we don't but Jesus can give it
to us the Holy Spirit is here and he can
give it to us but the only way to get it
is to die die now 2 self and when you
die to self you say yes to inspiration
isn't that true and if you don't die to
self you go outside of inspiration and
you start looking at the Mystics that
are out there for the last 5,000 years
and you start thinking about what they
teach and you start getting involved
with the mysticism of the emerging
Church contemplative prayer centering
prayer altered states of consciousness
all for excitement but folks we've got
all of the light in the world that says
don't go near that stuff like I said
last night when you do when you choose
to violate the council that we have the
inspired Council Satan begins to weave
his thoughts into our thoughts it's a
form of hypnotism Ellen White calls it a
branch of hypnotism and it changes us
but we think we're
shipping Jesus having a wonderful
experience in the presence of God but
it's not the same God or the same power
or the same spirit that those that go to
the spirit of prophecy in scripture for
inspiration there's something different
and something different now we talk
about people here you know please
remember this is not about them it's
about what is being taught to God's
people you need to hear the truth don't
you alright and that's why like you know
I know when I when I wrote the Omega
rebellion and meet it I I wanted the
support of the spirit of prophecy I
wanted it there when I read the book
that the emerging church that has come
into our church through the teachings of
the one project the book that they use
the green cord dream the theology Ellen
White I mean it was a it was nice to
have the green cord dream as the title
of the book but all the recommendations
in that book are mystics and teachers of
spiritual formation advocates of that
teaching to read their books have a list
here of names let me read them to you
richard Foster Darren Kimball Mike
DeSean Tony Jones Dallas Willard Brendan
Manning Beth Moore Doug Padgett rob bell
tony jones henri nouwen you ever heard a
henry now these are Roman Catholic
priests who have revived mysticism
within the church that's what I'm going
to talk about interspersed with
my own story here Thomas Keating major
player in the last hundred years you
know back in the 1950s and 60s bringing
Eastern gurus over to his monastery in
Massachusetts to learn the meditative
practices that alter consciousness this
is what it's all about folks it's all
about altering the state of
consciousness that you're in to put you
in a place where demonic powers can
control you for we wrestle not against
flesh and blood but against the
principalities and powers the the
darkness that exists in the supernatural
realms they want to get into your mind
and that's what this is all about that's
what the emerging church is all about
that's what spiritual formation is all
about to get into your minds to control
you last night I mentioned the
sacraments I'm going to talk about that
again this morning the sacraments are
the means through which mysticism is
used to enter into your minds and we
read it to you Romanism as a system is
no more in harmony with the gospel of
christ now than at any former period in
history it's the same today same goals
now when I talk about romanism the Roman
Catholic Church when I talk about the
one project when I talk about the green
cord dream folks it's not about the
people okay it's about the teaching the
system of worship that is deceptive that
is satanic all right it is and the the
only way you know it's satanic is that
we have inspiration to keep us on the
straight and narrow path and when you
study inspiration and you see all the
warnings including what Ellen White says
it is those who will not heed the
warnings that God has given that fall
into
this endtime apostasy okay we've got to
heed the warnings that's our guideline
we can't figure these things out on our
own we don't have that power we're
wrestling with supernatural power so the
only way to gain victory is to make sure
that you are aligned with the proper
truthful supernatural power and that has
to do with inspiration that's how you
tell it's the spirit of prophecy that
guides us along the way and that's why
you'll see very little spirit of
prophecy a downplay of the spirit of
prophecy in the emerging church
teachings no no they don't want to hear
that not that that separates us from
them of course it does it's meant to
it's made to separate us just like God
told nation of Israel don't mingle with
the Philistines around you be separate
God wants us to be separate he wants us
to to mingle with them and ass at a
certain level but not to go back to them
thinking that we can find light no
because the Lord says I will give all
the light you need to you without you
having to go to those who are in
darkness and error that's a simple
segment and then I read that one
statement and I say I should not be
reading this other material because
Satan will weave the fine threads of his
thoughts into my mind and material that
I would have ran from been afraid of I
learned to love and that's exactly
what's happening in the emerging church
ok now the emerging church is a an
attempt to regain the support of
Protestantism to undo the Protestant
Reformation the counter-reformation it's
still going on and the Jesuits were
expert at it expert they knew exactly
what to do get the young people
get the young people in the schools all
right with this flowery worship system
believe me Roman Catholicism is
impressive that's an impressive worship
service and their theology if you do not
know the truth makes more sense than
jumping across views in the charismatic
movement you know it's solid it's
steadfast they got the most beautiful
music and the finest culture in the
world and it attracts the fall in nature
and the biggest deception of Roman
Catholicism is that you can still go to
heaven while you're sinning oh that's a
temptation you know sin well you know
God forgives me it's his grace you know
I confess my sins so you get the best of
both worlds right you can live in this
world like revelation 18 teaches us that
the church the false Church enters into
this this relationship with the world
with the businesses of the world with
these recent couple of popes have spoken
of it's just it's just incredible they
want to control the economy of the world
and they want to set up a moral system
that they are in charge of and they
actually have written you need someone
to make all the decisions with this new
globalization this new world order and
it can't be the United Nations they've
proven themselves inept it can't be any
country because they have their own
selfish interests in mind he wouldn't
name who it should be it should be
somebody that the whole world looks up
to but he wouldn't name the Roman
Catholic Church but that was the only
one left they want to control the moral
structure of the world and they will for
a very short period of time before Jesus
comes back they will control the
listen she is employing every device to
extend her influence and increase her
power in preparation for a fierce and
determined conflict to regain control of
the world great controversy to
reestablish persecution and undo all
that Protestantism has done Catholicism
is gaining ground on every side well
sure is now again remember the reason
you exist is to call people out of
Babylon to join with God's church right
I mean most of God's final church is out
there in the Roman Catholic Church and
in the Protestant churches and
everywhere else in the world and that's
what we have been raised up for to give
this three angels message to the world
you won't hear three angels message in
the emerging church or in the one
project even you just won't okay it's
not there because it separates because
everybody else has three angels message
what's that who are you folks seeing the
desire is to want to break down all the
barriers that separate and that's what
mysticism does it breaks down the
barriers because the minds of all the
people from different religions
different backgrounds all start to be
influenced by the same demonic powers
I'm going to read a little to you I
don't have overheads but the following
segment was copied directly from an
editorial in the februari 2012 edition
of inside the Vatican I get these
publications because I want to keep up
on what's going on my mailman must be
very confused i get i get papers from
all these different religions you know
probably wondering who is this guy
anyway it is written by the editor dr.
Robert Moynihan many of you probably
know who that is and contains quotations
from a message given by Pope Benedict
the 16th that will be read in all Roman
Catholic churches on Youth Day May
twelfth 2012 now I'm just going to jump
down to the last paragraph the Pope says
silence has been a key part of Christian
life from the earliest times site and
he's talking about the supernatural
state of silence he points to the
eloquence of God's love lived to the
point of the supreme gift which is
seeing the supreme gift which is seen in
quote the silence of the cross you know
how there was silence for half an hour
or something like he's correlating that
with the silence when after Christ's
death there was a great silence over the
earth silent contemplation also immerses
us in the source of that love so the
Roman Catholic theology is that you get
immersed in God's love and grace as your
consciousness alters through mysticism
into that state of the silence I mean
this is a real science folks as a
science and then it says who directs us
toward our neighbors so that we may feel
their suffering and offer than the light
of the Cross the social gospel the
social gospel which
been picked up by the emerging church
that's why god is in everybody we love
everybody we let anybody in everybody in
say and that's the Roman Catholic
theology what do you got to do is go to
confession anyway and then you're free
and clear it makes it very simple for
the carnal nature to run your life and
still think that you're on your pathway
to heaven listen last part of the send
who directs us toward our neighbors so
that we may feel their suffering and
offer than the light of Christ his
message of life and his saving gift of
the fullness of love we're in the
silence so that you can be immersed into
this power where you receive grace and
that's what I said the other night last
night about the sacraments being being a
source of mystical experience listen the
liturgy or the sacraments offers the
deepest and most effective answer to
this yearning for an encounter with God
this is out of the catechism of the
catholic church pastors must ensure that
this sense of mystery penetrates
consciences the mystery of the silence
the mystery of mysticism making them
rediscover the art of mystic God mr.
gajic catechesis or mystical teaching
this is in their catechism now the
mystical teaching of the sacraments must
be rediscovered so dear this mystical
teaching so dear to the Fathers of the
Church the Desert Fathers going all the
way back they learn this mystical
teaching and now I'm going to read to
you the thing that probably just was the
most impressive to me that opened my
mind as to what what the
ends of Roman Catholicism are this is a
document from Vatican to instructing
churches around the world on mission
activity the instruction is filled with
information on the importance of
spiritual formation to the success of
their outreach program since the
contemplative this is quote since the
contemplative life belongs to the
fullness of the church's presence let it
be put into practice everywhere in other
words what they're saying look this
mystical silence contemplative prayer is
owned by the Roman Catholic Church we
are the owners of it it's ours and let
it be put into practice everywhere the
contemplative life consists of those
mystical teachings learned in the
discipline called spiritual formation
brought to us through the visions of
Ignatius Loyola founder of the Jesuits
the document first claims that these
teachings belong to the Roman Catholic
Church and should we put into practice
everywhere for what purpose would they
want to put this into practice
everywhere the document answers by
saying these words listen carefully
religious institutes of the
contemplative and of the act of life
have so far played and still do play the
main role in the evangelization of the
world not that this is in Vatican to add
Jen T's on mission activity of the
church the main role in the
evangelization of the world what
contemplative prayer mysticism this is
what we're going to use to bring the
world back to Roman Catholicism you know
the European Union had a letter sent out
to all administrators that were Roman
Catholic in all the nations that make up
the European you
and telling them they will never succeed
unless all of them begin to practice
contemplative prayer imaginary came from
the church to the Roman Catholic leaders
of the nation's Germany France all the
countries in Europe we're told you got a
sutler doing this learn this why because
Satan and takes over the minds of those
people believe me the Roman Catholic
Church looks at the world and says first
we gotta win back Europe which we lost
in 1798 and after we win back Europe
then we'll go to the rest of the world
will control the rest of the world and
they will because America will fall
eventually as sad as it seems it's just
I don't like thinking about it you know
how God has blessed this country but the
sunday laws will come and we're told the
next thing that will happen is national
ruined national ruin Oh politics that's
another hour believe that
I want to tell you about brother craw
and then I'll get into couple stories
brother craw was an Adventist missionary
Ellen White wrote him a letter this is
in 13 manuscript releases page 394 in
the letter that he Ellen White was
asking for funds to fund missionary
activity from brother crow and she says
this we have no time to lose trouble
asst times are before us the world is
stirred with the spirit of war soon the
scenes of trouble spoken of in the
prophecies will take place the prophecy
in the 11th of daniel has nearly reached
its complete fulfillment much of the
history now listen much of the history
that has taken place in fulfillment of
this prophecy will be repeated this is a
prophecy in Daniel 11 that we don't look
at very often we look at verse 42 or 36
all the way to the end of the chapter
when Michael stands up you know the king
of the north and the King of the South
battle well before that is what happened
during the Dark Ages and much of it will
be repeated and yeah it will be repeated
woman like we just read they desire to
bring back persecution and control of
the world now listen much of the history
that has taken place in fulfillment of
this prophecy will be repeated in the
30th verse a power is spoken of that
shall be grieved this is the king of the
north now the papacy that shall be
grieved and returned and have
intelligence against the holy Covenant
wait a minute now this is the part that
she says will be repeated and then she
quotes this so shall he do he shall even
return and have intelligence with them
that forsake the holy Covenant now folks
this is this word intelligence it's the
only time it's used in the Bible Daniel
uses this it's unique word let me tell
you what it means it's a complicated
meaning but it means to observe choose
pick out and educate choose and this is
all has a secretive component to it you
know to observe to find people who what
who were who had indignation against the
holy Covenant now who's got the holy
Covenant in the world today who has
entered into a holy covenant with God
today aside from individual people God
has one church in this world right the
seventh-day adventist church that he
raised up that is in covenant
relationship with him so this is talking
about people in the seventh day
adventist church who have indignation
against the holy Covenant they are
observed by the papacy that's what this
is saying they looked at their chosen to
be educated think about that people in
our church that have been chosen zeroed
in on and educated in a false teaching
you know our friends involved with the
one project and I say friends they are
our friends they're our church members
they're our brothers and sisters Lord
God please help them to see this with a
what they've done four of the five
leaders that put together the one
project went to george fox university to
get their doctorates degree in emerging
church culture they sat at the feet of
leonard sweet
a self-proclaimed mystic and practice or
these things leader of the emerging
church he was the mentor that they all
had to get their doctor's degree and
again folks this is not about them it's
what they chose to do they went to sit
for years at the feet of the teachers of
Babylon so to Satan have time to weave
the fine threads of his teachings into
their minds absolutely you know that's
why when you when you look at the books
recommended they're all advocates of
spiritual formation dr. Brian bless his
heart I believe with all my heart it was
believes he's doing the right thing his
doctoral thesis had a bibliography of
over a hundred people every single
person in the bibliography is an
advocate of spiritual formation a
teacher of spiritual formation a pastor
who believes in spiritual formation know
I'd Vanessa over a hundred in the
bibliography every single one of them a
believer in spiritual formation are we
ignoring inspiration when we do
something like that and when we form
this one project from the teachings of
Jurgen maltman alright that's who he
says they went to and her paper that he
wrote about a month ago he says it was
after that that meeting in Denver
whether you all got together and and
prayed about how to help the adventist
church and they switched from
Christology to ecclesiology and they
switched from christology to
ecclesiology being the most important
aspect of what they had to do because
jesus was standing outside the door
according to dr. brian of the adventist
church knocking can I come in a
misapplication of that prophecy Jesus
isn't standing outside the door of this
church he's standing outside the door
the hearts
of the people in the church and he is
the head of the church right now he's
the head of the church and this has come
into the church in fulfillment of this
testimony the minister's page 112 when
the shaking comes by the introduction of
false theories to get that these surface
readers anchored know we're all like
sifting sand they slide into any
position to suit the tenor of their
feelings of bitterness and that fits
with what we read in Isaiah last night
they were ashamed people in our own
church ashamed of our church why can't
we be accepted by the sisterhood of
Protestant churches out there I'm tired
being different tired of being looked at
as peculiar that's what's happening but
when you read the concept of who they
believe Babylon consists of you'll see
why they think that way they believe
that Babylon are all of the fourth
nations in the world not churches I have
a paper that came out today in a
publication called the Sabbath Herald
and it explains it's a counter of dr.
Allen's paper that he wrote about a
month ago from Walla Walla and I point
out that he's got Jesus outside the
church he's got Moulton's philosophy and
theology it's it's that theology from
Altman that created this thought in his
mind we've got to deal with ecclesiology
not christology because jesus isn't even
in the church well he isn't even in the
church because he's following what
maltman believes is Babylon that's not
what we believe is Babylon follow check
out the Sabbath herald online you'll see
it it's the main article that's in there
this this week but it exposed
all of this well this letter went to
brother Prague they going to have
intelligence roman catholicism
intelligence with those who have
forsaken the holy Covenant in the
seventh day adventist church and she
must have meant you know when you say
aspects of the history will be repeated
and then you quote that one verse that's
got to be the worse at least one of them
so that intelligence part and folks now
we have a Jesuit Pope don't we very
interesting very interesting they are
dedicated to take over the world for
their master Pope Francis and he's taken
over the world pretty much himself isn't
he the whole world looks up to them and
it's because they didn't have that
people jumping over fuse in the
charismatic movements because they're
solid culturally educationally they got
the best teachers the best schools they
know what they're doing they know how to
do it and to think for us to think to be
afraid to even say the word Jesuit today
because we'll be labeled as being a
little bit off is insane that's the
organization that Loyola started to
place the Pope and power number one in
the world and you think they don't still
have the same goal you think they're
going to ignore the seventh-day
adventist church the one church they
know that has the truth in this world
you think they just go don't worry about
that church we are the center of their
focus behind the scenes of course they
would never come out and say that but we
are the center of their focus and the
teachings in the emerging church and the
methods use the philosophy to win people
over is all Jesuit philosophy that's
where it comes from
right out of their handbook Spiritual
Exercises of Ignatius Loyola that's
mysticism all the way so this is why I
started last night nice and look we're
all of us in this church right now will
be under a supernatural power either
gods or Satan's I mean there is a middle
ground God has his time that he gives us
to make our choices but believe me you
are not smart enough to do this on your
own that's why God gave us the testimony
of Jesus all right that's what we have
it for and of course you can see why it
will be Satan's final attack against
against the spirit of prophecy to make
it of none effect Whittle of course not
because those who follow it will be
heeding the warnings that God has given
and will be saved from the Omega
deception so simple as that so we all
have to choose and an hour job the
leaders that are up here of this
movement we're not here that clean the
church up we're not we're here to supply
the information that you need to make a
choice because the shaking is coming
that's all alright so we're not talking
about people the angels will separate
the wheat and the tears at the end we
need to love our brothers and sisters
that have been caught up in this and
pray for them be willing to die to them
Jesus died for me while I was yet his
enemy hard for us to fathom that in our
carnal nature alright but my life was
more important than his the creator of
the universe come on infinite power love
speaks the word and galaxies appear and
he looked my life more than he looked
his own that's the love of God that
generates through
heaven it's a power it's a power that is
cannot be deep it cannot be defeated
love cannot be defeated because it's
selfless all the power of the enemy is
selfish you don't want to confess stick
you made a mistake that's the carnal
nature these folks that are into the
emerging church that see that Ellen
White warned against doing such things
what's holding them back from being able
to say I made a mistake pride that's why
I'm going to share this story with you
there was a statement that Ellen White
made that nobody in this world has the
right to speculate on the presence of
Jesus where God is located or about his
personality now I had trouble with that
for a year I kept thinking about that
what does she mean when she says that I
mean the personality of Jesus we always
think about his character what he's like
but then finally one day it dawned on me
thank you Holy Spirit go back and look
at the dictionary Ellen White's day and
find out how the word personality was
used we use the word personality to
describe a person's character what they
like not so back then it meant
personhood the nature of their life why
and how are they alive is what
personality meant okay very interesting
so Ellen White said nobody has a right
to think about that and nobody has a
right to think about where the presence
of God is located well what are you
doing you go into the silence are you
under the influence thinking that you
can control the presence of God sure you
close your eyes you go into some altered
state and gods going to appear to me
I'm in control of his presence I'm the
one who calls the shots I say now God I
have five minutes I'm going to go inside
I'm going to meditate please appear to
me what are we kidding the selfishness
of that who do we think we are that we
can control where God is at what time it
may almost seem like it's okay but it's
not okay and we're told in the spirit of
prophecy that is not okay don't
speculate on where God is or on how he
has life leave it alone his nature so
people who are upset with our church get
called out of our church into the
schools of Babylon okay because the
fantasy has intelligence with them they
taught these things and then they bring
these things back into God's church hmmm
and you're gonna have to decide who's
right i I just beg of you stick with the
spirit of prophecy the testimony of
Jesus and Scripture okay because that's
what's lacking on the other side here
now last night I talked about overcoming
by the word of our testimony oh this is
so important folks okay that you have a
testimony and you do have a testimony
you know Alan gave a testimony at the
meeting inside so it's not only my
testimony alright by which I overcome
but it's the testimony of others who
said that God led them to the Omega
rebellion and they were using that to
judge the course that they were taking
and to get their doctorates degree that
caused him and his his teacher to go
head-to-head so it's his testimony to
that's a part of my testimony that says
God had me right
book because he's used other people he's
used me you know he spoke to my heart
when he said you know Rick you gotta
write a book about this you know I knew
those words loud and clear because Ken
spoke them to me a hundred times and
then on that very morning those of you
that weren't here last night the very
morning I began after ten years of
waiting to write this book when I
started to write that book for people
came walking in my church and one of
them was a vice president of Pacific
press didn't even know that where they
were driving but they wound up in front
of my church at the very moment that I
started and began writing that book and
she said we need a book like that and
she spent an over an hour with me
telling me who to contact how to write
it you know I'm not a writer but it was
it was edification it was verification
from God that yes I want you to write
that book okay and then the other story
I told you about how when people accuse
you critically you don't know what
you're talking about this is not right
this is wrong now you're speaking
negatively about the church did you use
Matthew 18 to go talk to them you know
they've got all kinds of things anything
but the spirit of prophecy to stand
behind what they teach that's what's
missing in the emerging church that's
what's missing in the one project in our
church now after I finished writing the
Omega rebellion I told the Lord I don't
want to have anything to do with the
publishing of this book I don't know
when you want to come out but I know
it's going to cause contention in the
church so I want you to bring it out
when you feel it's the time to wring it
out so I will have nothing to do with it
get it published without me and that was
my prayer for a year and a half
I waited and waited and waited very
frustrating to have a book that you know
it you feel is going to save lives and
reveal truth and you see you see these
other organizations with the deception
growing with power and people falling
into it but then God spoke to my heart
you said yeah Rick alright these errors
will be brought into the church I'm
letting them in not you I'm allowing
this to take place why to bring about
the shaking folks that's for real God is
in charge of this church the Lord is in
charge nothing gets by him nothing gets
taught in this church without him
permitting it to be taught he's allowing
it so you know don't criticize the
church because of it the church is
filled with sinners with people that
have free will and God is allowing
people to make mistakes and some of them
make mistakes and and learn the truth
and repent and others don't they saw
teaching false teachings within the
church well God doesn't just cut them
off ring like that no he lets those
false teachings grow so that you can
make a decision he's in charge he knows
what he's doing we all have to make
decisions and they will be a shaking yes
they will be most of us will be shaken
out with hope that's right
well it was about a year and a half
later that I was in the dome down in
Atlanta and Ted Wilson was elected
president and he gave his sermon the go
forward sermon in which he said don't go
outside the church to learn spiritual
formation Wow finally you know God was
waiting the Ted to get elected okay and
by the way Ted endorsed my book with a
whole full-page endorsement that would
have been on the back cover but he had
to he had to withdraw it he was told on
the day it went to printing that the VRI
has to approve any book that the
conference president the general
conference president endorses and it
would have taken a year another year
from that point so he just had to
withdraw it so I just took this
statement from his sermon and put it on
the back cover that was public don't go
outside the church to learn spiritual
formation so what happens two weeks
later there's a worship conference in
California from the North American
division John Ortberg George Barna the
rest of them all invited from outside
the church it's like Ted Wilson said
nothing very strange very strange and
it's happened right up to this day same
thing just ignoring that ignoring that
Leonard sweets books handed out you know
to everyone that comes to the one
project meeting it's you know this is
mysticism what are we handing that book
out for I mean you know these folks have
a wonderful truth as a part of their
message but it's a mixture of truth in
error so why would our leaders why would
our teachers and pastors go to learn
from a mixture of truth and error
thinking that they have the ability to
choose the good from the evil they don't
they don't because they're angels have
to back away that protect them half the
away evil angels move in and like I said
a dozen times so far we've the fine
threads of their thoughts into the
thoughts of those who go and sit at the
feet of these teachers of truth in error
why not just study the truth we've got
it all right the testimony of Jesus
we've got it it's all there I don't have
to worry about deciphering and picking
out the truth from the error so when it
comes to light when not to go to these
other teachers and other books now if
you gain gaining an education for
educational purposes for analytical
purposes for research it's fine to read
those books if God has led you to get a
degree in that way and you have to read
books like that that's fine but don't go
there for light why because of God has
any new light to shine upon his people
he will give it to them without their
having to go to those who are in
darkness and era that's it I don't need
more than that one statement I don't
need to go to those who are in darkness
and error and that's george fox
university for years to sit there at the
feet of these men who are mystics who
are teaching them error and think that
you're smart enough to take the good out
of the bed that's the excuse that most
of these people use well we know the
truth so we can take the good and leave
the bed over the contemplative prayer
and the centering prayer is the good
that you've taken there are those that
practice that on a daily basis in our
church leaders who teach it of course
they don't want to be upfront with that
they go to the back with that well there
I am at the Dome in Atlanta listening to
this and I knew now's the time and then
within a short period of time I don't
know how long I get a phone call
somebody in California Rick wants you to
call them back four times I think
finally I'm driving into my driveway and
the phone's ringing again it's at Cal
upon your number and and I said well
when I'm pulling into my parking space
my wife Rosa is coming out and she gets
that phone call just came again from
California so my phone ringing I'm
looking at and I'm gone let me see who
this is so hello this is Rick Pastor
Rick yes you got a minute I want a story
to tell you it's dan East River right up
here he's very persistent and he called
and he called and he called and he tells
me this story it was incredible he said
he just heard about spiritual formation
he was learning about this subject and
he called her bugless who told you to
call her Douglas the Lord okay and he
called her Douglas and in the middle of
a conversation with herb my name came up
herb said you need to talk with Rick
Howard and okay so he had that name in
his head and then about an hour and a
half later he winds up on the phone with
somebody else who knew a pastor a pastor
in chula vista yeah el cajon down there
and he was the associate pastor and his
senior pastor was involved with
spiritual formation and he was having to
deal with it and that pastor told him he
said you need to get in touch with Rick
Howard and he was looking for a
manuscript because do we have somebody
in our church that has written something
well this pastor had my manuscript this
is the pastor that Rosie and I moved
next door to 35 years ago as God led us
from the occult into the seventh day
adventist church John lupins he's here
in California he's written a book called
New York assemble so he talks to John
and John says I've got the manuscript
and what do you do email it to you and
you and Carly read it he gave me my
phone number okay
it's a little vague back there of how it
happened but to see how God works this
is the man who was persistent enough to
then called white hall at remnant never
thinking he'd ever get him but he called
him and he spent half an hour on the
phone you told him about this manuscript
that he's just read so he said send it
to us he sent it to them then the next
thing i know i'm getting a call from
remnant they want to print the book i
had nothing to do with it it was outside
of my hands and I knew this was the time
that God was choosing to get the book
printed all right and God used Danny to
do this whole thing and if you know
Danny when he gets fixed on something it
gets done and it did he was a perfect
person for God to use to do such a thing
and it's just amazing see it's when
somebody comes up now and says Ricky
weren't influenced by your life in the
you know in spiritualism didn't mess
your mind up isn't that why you're
teaching these things today no let me
tell you my testimony of how God has
worked time at the time after time
leading me to Bible texts that i needed
leading me to two concepts people you
know I was the only one writing about
this subject I said Lord this got to be
others you're not going to use one
person to bring some kind of a truth to
the whole church you use many different
people with the same truth and I said
there's got to be others out there Lord
you have them contact me I have to know
that I'm not alone in this but I don't
want to make any phone calls so I I
didn't want to be the one to conjure up
you know somebody else if they're there
bring them on the next day somebody from
amazing facts called a lady with a bible
study interest she gives me the bible
study interest and then says do you know
anything about spiritual formation
this is the day after I started praying
our prayer I said Lord you've got the
long story short within a week or two
Joel Tomkins herb Douglas people from
across the country from the east coast
to the west coast call me Rick I heard
you doing this I heard you doing that I
heard you doing this no wonder God
didn't impress me to write a book one of
them heard said that herb said I think I
often wondered why I wasn't impressed to
write a book about this whole subject he
goes now I know why God's having you
write the book I'm right oh no that was
Joel Tomkins and he said I'm writing
letters to the conference presidents
everywhere don't think they haven't been
warned about this they know about it
they were told about it you know I don't
understand why it's plain as day in the
spirit of prophecy don't fool around
with the supernatural leave it alone
don't go back to Babylon thinking that
you can find truth to apply to your
spiritual life you can't you'll get
mixed up and confused that's what
babylons all about confusion follow what
I'm saying we went to spirit mediums
Hindu gurus Santana was a brother
disciple rock and roll guys Santana we'd
meet twice a week I became a disciple of
this guru because well I was interested
in Hinduism I was afraid of the spirit
medium that I went to and I wanted to
leave that alone and they gave me this
picture of this guru they said you go
home and meditate on this picture and I
did I went home set that picture up at
the moment my eyes met the eyes of this
guru who was in the state they call
somebody you know one with God as soon
as my eyes met his eyes I was paralyzed
I stopped breathing flames were
shooting out of the picture his face
would appear and disappear and I'm now
it's like totally focused on this it
lasted about I don't know 30 seconds a
minute and then it just went went away
and I got up I went in the living are
supposedly let me tell you okay all
right and and I told her what happened
and then the next day I stopped at the
ashram on the way up to work i worked in
Stanford Connecticut lived in Long
Island and would drive by this ashram up
a new shell and I gave him the picture
back because I gave them a picture of my
family and I told the leader of that
ashram what happened she said oh that's
wonderful that means you have a soul
connection with the Guru and we got word
back that you've been accepted into his
highest order of disciples you know and
that's where Santana was in some news
casters from channel 7 TV in New York
this was a big deal he was a spiritual
leader at the United Nations but it was
a year later after he told me that the
Bible was true and that he was my Savior
that i came across acts 4 12 that said
there's no other name given among men
whereby we must be saved so I asked a
question I said you know your savior but
the Bible that you say is truth says
Jesus is the only Savior what am I going
to do with that well you just accept
what you accept and deny the rest you
know that kind of you decide what you
want to accept out of the Bible there's
lots of truth in there and that was it I
said god I quit this is in five years
I've lost my mind I can't discover what
the truth is you need to take over my
life and leave me you know where the
truth is I don't so I'm not looking
anymore my search has led me down one
dead end road after another it's over
well within a day or two I got a call
Union Carbide that said we'd like you to
come in for an interview I a year ago I
sent out resumes this is the first
response I had I went they offered me
the job I took it i went up to look at a
new house to live in Rosie and I were
together with the with a landlord who
lived in a mansion and the back five
acres of this estate and he's showing us
the house it was perfect just what we
needed we had two little children you
know little three three bedrooms cedar
cedar cedar shake cottage so we're
looking at it and I look next door and I
see a house through the trees and I said
you know if we move to you who we're on
next door neighbor be and he said now
you gotta remember where my head's at
every day all day long I'm saying God is
it the occult and the supernatural and
Hinduism or is it the Holy Bible which
am I supposed to believe and I'm waiting
for an answer to that question and when
I asked him I said who would my neighbor
be he said you know I don't know his
name all I know is that he's a minister
I almost fainted I knew God was leading
with I said what church said seventh-day
Adventists I said who
I was 28 years old I never heard of the
seventh-day Adventist Church ever and I
was born and raised in New I park where
the conference office was never heard of
it Seth day who you see for Rosie and I
it was the next insanity to our family
that's all we were going from one
craziness to another to another to
another they watched her for five years
and now it's a seven-day Evan a strict
but I knew God led me there I knew he
led me there and I said I gotta find out
with these people who leave and I drove
John lupins nuts for the next year show
it to me in the Bible don't just tell me
I want to see it and folks we got the
message it tied the Bible together from
Genesis to Revelation in a way that I've
never you know I 45 years I'm struggling
with this book and now all of a sudden i
wish i had another hour to tell you the
stories of how God led me through the
great controversy but I've got to stop
but God led us it's the word of our
testimony that gives us victory people
can tell me I'm crazy all they want they
can criticize as long as I can line up
the way God has led me through his
Providence I can feel safe and confident
in his love and so can you but you're
going to have to study you're being
presented with information now you've
got to study this information for
yourself god bless you
you